[Music]
ursula kayla green's
short story the rule of names is
set within the earth-sea narrative
universe that she's going to
build out over decades and there's a
number of
important key themes that are going to
show up in the novels
and other short stories that are being
developed or at least referenced here
in this story it's also a great tale
just on its own lights because
we're getting to see you know kind of
it's almost like a detective story
with a twist in the end as
we'll talk about in just a moment so
the first thing we encounter is this mr
underhill who is a wizard
but not much of a wizard he's a rather
mediocre type and he's not only
mediocre as a wizard he's also kind of
you know middling as a man
as well there's this you know wonderful
description
of him here after we get past him you
know huffing and puffing
uh the villagers see him
and and here's what she has to say he
was
all the little island head in the way of
a wizard and and so he deserved respect
but
how could you respect a little fat man
of 50 who waddled along with his toes
turned in
breathing steam and smiling he was no
great shakes as a workman either his
fireworks were fairly elaborate but his
elixirs were weak
warts he charmed off frequently
reappeared after three days
tomatoes he enchanted grew no bigger
than cantaloupes in those
rare times when a strange ship stopped
at saturn's harbor
mr underhill always stayed under his
hill for
fear he explained of the evil eye
he was in other words a wizard the way
walleyed gann was a carpenter by default
the villagers made do with badly hung
doors and inefficient spells for this
generation
and they relieved their annoyance by
treating mr underhill quite familiarly
as a mere fellow villager and so you
know what we've got here is this guy
who clearly you know there's that old
joke what do you you know what do you
call the person who graduates
at the bottom of their medical school
class
doctor he's a wizard in more or less the
same way
as she says by default he's the best
that they've got to work with
and that's it he's shy he
doesn't look like much you know they
he he puts up with them treating him in
very familiar
ways his magic is kind of haphazard a
little bit later
one woman relates a story about him
curing a cat
of the mange but unfortunately the mange
if you don't know is is a disease that
makes hair fall out
it's an orange cat and the hair that
grows in is gray and this is like
perfectly representative
of him he's you know retiring he doesn't
like people
delving into his stuff and he
you know he does his share of things but
he's just not very good at it
a little bit later they describe him
wanting to hang out with older people
he's shy a young around the young men
and then we get this vignette where he
is going along getting you know the
stuff he's going to get at market and he
runs into
a school being taught now everybody's
basically illiterate on this island so
they're not
using chalkboards or books or anything
like that here we go the school was
being held this day out on the commons
since no one on saturn's eye when
island was literate there were no books
to learn from and no desks to carve
initials on and no blackboards to erase
and in fact no schoolhouse
on rainy days the children met in the
loft of the communal barn
and got hay in their pants on sunny days
the school teacher
palani took them anywhere she felt like
today
surrounded by 30 interested children
under 12 and 40 uninterested sheep under
five she was teaching an important item
on the curriculum
the rule of names now this is what the
story is itself named after the title
right
and within the earth sea universe the
way that
leguin is setting it up names are
incredibly
important and what we're getting here is
is peeling things
a little bit like an onion what is it
that's so important
about names so she asks the students
what are the things governing
these she says you know the rule of
names already children there are two
and they're the same on every island in
the world what's
one of them it ain't polite to ask
anybody what his name is shouted a fat
quick boy interrupted by a little girl
shrieking
you can't never tell your own name to
nobody my ma says
and so you've got in the lingo of island
children two of the you could call them
sub rules of names don't ask don't tell
don't ask
other people what their name is don't
tell your own name to
other people now we have to make some
qualifications here does that mean that
everybody on these islands and everybody
in the world of earth sea
wanders around not knowing who anybody
is no
because you have some other names
sort of like the you know the external
thing we could call them
nicknames if you like as opposed to our
given names we're used to using
our given names as our names although
sometimes you people may surprise you
they may have
you know a confirmation name that you
never find out about until you get
particularly close to them you might not
even know that they were confirmed and
given a name or there might be
other names as well so there are what we
can call
child names right the names that are
given to children
by their parents they're going to get a
true name
later given names prime example of that
is mr underhill he lives under a hill
there you go that's his name or
blackbeard you know he's a guy who sails
in
he's got a black beard there you go
the other names like bert would maybe be
child names that just made it into
adulthood because they're living in the
same place or they could be
given names and then we have
true names the name that is
at the core of who you are
here it gets a bit deeper
so they ask you know the children is mr
underhill
actually is this his true name and they
say no and
they say how do you know it's not his
true name because he came here all alone
and so there wasn't
anybody knew his true name so they
couldn't tell us and he couldn't
very good super poppy don't shout that's
right even a wizard
can't tell his true name when you
children go through school and go
through the passage
you'll leave your child names behind and
keep only your true names which you must
never ask for
and never give away why is that the rule
and
this is where we get to the real
rule of names there are these external
rules governing behavior
and then there is the deeper reality
governing not just names but things and
power
and magic that is the reason
the cause the why behind
all of this mr underhill
reveals this because the name is the
thing
he said in his shy soft husky voice
and the true name is the true thing to
speak the name
is to control the thing am i right
school mistress
and that is the correct answer that's
being given to the children
when you possess the true name
of something you can
control you can even coerce over master
it
if it's a thing like a rock or
a body of water or a tree
you can get that thing to do what it is
that you want
you can bend it to your will if it's a
person or perhaps even a dragon
or some other sentient creature
you can force it to remain
in its shape or to assume it's one true
shape
so the name is incredibly powerful and
there are ways that you can get it we
find out that
one can in fact acquire a name not just
through say learning
or being given the name but through
black magic
that would reveal somebody's name
so now the next thing to talk about is
this reference to
wizards warlocks and mages because we
have a
stranger show up to tone we already have
a wizard right
but perhaps this guy is something
more why because he's sailing in
on a ship there was only one man aboard
the ship
old sea captain fageno when they told
him that drew down a bristle of white
brows over his unseeing eyes
there's only one kind of man he said
that sails the outer reach alone a
wizard
or a warlock or a mage so the vis
here's how leguin expresses it so the
villagers were breathless
hoping to see for once in their lives a
mage capital m
right this is something really special
one of the mighty white magicians of the
rich
towered crowded inner islands of the
archipelago
so being a mage is something more than
being a wizard
more than being a warlock what exactly
it is
we're not being told but we'll find that
out in other
leguin stories won't we so let's talk
about this guy blackbeard he shows up he
seems to be
uh you know a trader of sorts he's got
all sorts of stuff to sell
and you know he wants to acquire
information he's hanging around there
for a while and he learns from the
others telling stories about this
wizard this not particularly great and
rather shy and retiring wizard mr
underhill we also get introduced to bert
who is going to play a you know
interesting role in the story
particularly
at the end and then blackbeard tells a
story
so what we have here is the traditional
trope of
a story within a story that is revealing
what this story
is in fact genuinely about
and here's how it goes so he says
hold on bert i have a tale to tell you
before we meet your
wizard it's a story that starts started
a hundred years ago and isn't finished
yet
though it soon will be very soon now
that's a great pre-figuration
right there it will be solved it will be
resolved very soon but not quite in the
way that the story
is leading us to think so he says
in the very heart of the archipelago so
this is earth sea right the archipelago
is the islands
where the islands crowd thick as flies
on honey there's a little isle called
pandora
the sea lords of pandora were mighty men
in the old days of war be before the
league
loot and ransom and tribute came pouring
into pandora and they gathered a great
treasure there
long ago then from somewhere away out in
the west reach where dragons breed on
the lava
isles came one day a very mighty dragon
a black winged wise cunning monster full
of strength and subtlety and like all
dragons loving gold
and precious stones above all things he
killed the sea lord
and his soldiers and the people of
pandor fled in their ships by night they
fled away
and left the dragon coiled up in the
pandora towers there he stayed for a
hundred years
coming forth only once in a year or two
and he must eat
so he goes on and blackbeard says that
couldn't be endured forever nor the
thought of him sitting on all that
treasure
so after the league got strong and the
archipelago wasn't so busy with wars and
piracy
it was decided to attack pandora drive
out the dragon
and get the golden jewels for the
treasury of the league
so a huge fleet gathered from 50 islands
seven mages stood in the prows of the
seven strongest ships
and they sailed towards pandora they got
there they landed
nothing stirred the dragons go on
the bones of the old sea lord and his
men lay about in the castle courts
and on the stairs the tower rooms
wreaked a dragon
but there was no dragon and no treasure
knowing that he couldn't stand up to
seven mages the dragon had skipped out
they tracked him
and found he'd flown to a deserted
island up north called udrath
they followed his trail there and what
did they find bones again
his bones the dragons but no treasure a
wizard
some unknown wizard from somewhere must
have met him single-handed and defeated
and made off at the treasure right under
the league's nose so we've got this
really interesting story don't we
dragon comes kills the lords of pandora
takes their horde a great you know
uh fleet and
magical army comes to get him he's gone
he's skipped town
and then they track him down and all
they find are bones
but no treasure so there must be a
wizard out there somewhere who's got
this
treasure why does blackbeard actually
care about this
he says i am the
sea lord of pendor and
i'm gonna get this treasure he says that
must have been a powerful wizard and a
clever one first to kill a dragon second
to get off without leaving
a trace i've got an advantage you see
i have the i'm the descendant of the
lords of pender that treasure is mine
it's mine and it knows that it's mine
i've got this
you know staff that
that glows green and the green great
emerald is calling out to me
and now i know where it is and he says
i'm the sea lord of pandora and i will
have the gold my father's one and the
jewel my mother's war and the green
stone
they are mine now what's being implied
here
mr underhill is that wizard so mr
underhill
isn't as incompetent as
we have been led to believe instead he
is hyper-competent he could actually
kill a dragon on his own
and vanish without a trace with all of
that
so this is quite interesting is is
underhill
not the you know kind of schmucky guy
that we think he is
or maybe blackbeard is deceived about
that
so here's where blackbeard invites
beard to see the end to see
the story brought to its conclusion he
tells them
here we go you can tell your village
boobies the whole story after i've
defeated this wizard and gone
or you can come and watch if you're not
afraid you'll never get the chance again
to see a great wizard
in all of his power so beard
follows him and now we get the wizard
battle and there's this transformation
that's taking place and i won't run
through
all the transformations but it is a
battle not only of
magic but of wits you know
one comes forth as a lion the other
comes forth as a tiger tigers beat lions
right
one comes forth as a fire another comes
forth
as a cataract of water and other turns
into hills
finally blackbeard
pulls a trick and he
he says take any shape you wish mr
underhill
i can match you i want to look on my
treasure now big dragon little wizard
take your true shape
i command you by the power of your true
name
ye vowed so the true name right
going back to the rule of the names the
name
is the thing the true name compels the
true
shape of the person and
underhill stays there as the monstrous
dragon now blackbeard realizes
that things didn't quite add up in the
equation
so here we go burt could not move at all
not even to blink he coward staring
whether he would or not he saw the black
dragon
hang there in the air above blackbeard
he saw the fire lick like many tongues
from the scaly mouth
the steam jet from the red nostrils you
saw blackbeard's face grow white
white is chalk and the beard fringe lips
trembling
your name is yvowed yes said a great
husky hissing voice
my true name is yvowed and my true shape
is this shape but the dragon was killed
they found dragon bones on udrath island
and here we get this
wonderful line that was another dragon
said the dragon and
that was the miscalculation that
blackbeard
had made turns out that underhill
was not actually a wizard as such
but a dragon a dragon the entire time
there was no wizard who came along and
killed this
amazing terrifying dragon the dragon
just
killed another dragon and left it behind
or perhaps
didn't even have any connection with it
and took the treasure
here so that's the end of blackbeard
right and bert interestingly enough we
we get a little vignette
he well i'll read this to you it's it's
such a wonderful description
the fisherman got to his feet and ran he
ran across the commons scattering sheep
to right and left
and straight down the village street to
palani's father's house palani was out
in the
garden weeding the nasturtiums come with
me
bart bert gasped she stared he grabbed
her wrist and dragged her with him
she screeched a little but did not
resist he ran with her straight to the
pier pushed her into his fishing sloop
the queenie
untied the painter took up the oars and
set off rowing like a
demon the last that satan's island saw
of him and palani
was the queenie sail vanishing in the
direction of the nearest
island westward and the villagers are
all like well this is a strange turn of
events right blackbeard's gone i don't
know what happened to him and
look at bert and the school teacher of
runoff together
and then mr underhill yvowed
comes out the story ends
mr underhill had decided that his true
name was no longer a secret he might as
well drop his disguise
walking was a lot harder than flying and
besides it was a long
long time since he had had a real
meal and that is where the story ends
with the effects of the revelation
of mr underhill's true name
all of these key ideas and
themes collapsed into one
moment and we're left to imagine what is
going to happen
to the island after that but in the
process of this
what we've gotten to see is what happens
when wizards
battle each other and make mistakes as
well we've gotten to see
some vignettes of earth sea life on this
little island of satin uh
satins island with you know bert and and
his
school teacher that he loves also his
his uh
grandmother or you know the goodie and
we get to see something about the nature
of dragons but
most of all we get to see illustrated
and explain to us the rule of names that
the story itself
is titled by
you